so what we're gonna try and do is we're
gonna try and tackle the same idea of
tangents and normals but we're gonna
stay as far away from T as we possibly
can so I'm going to go right back to the
first line that we wrote down x squared
equals 4a y and I'm gonna write that guy
if x squared equals 4a Y and I want to
find a tangent to this thing I forget
about all the stuff you knew about
parameters before if I want to find a
tangent to this thing what information
do I need and engrave right how do I
find the gradients of functions again I
I differentiate thank God I know how to
differentiate this isn't a weird form to
differentiate though right I I'm used to
having on the left hand side y equals
this is sort of geared in a little weird
way so let's just make the left hand
side y equals how do i what do I do to
both sides I'll divide by that pesky for
a and that'll get Y on its own I might
as well swap sides while I'm at it
okay that looks good this is all ready
for differentiating which of course I
have to do because I don't just know the
per hour which is the gradient I have to
actually do the legwork to get there in
this case dy on DX is going to be equal
to what so the power comes down the
front that's a four and then you can
cancel so far so good
does that look alright okay now at this
point we say I've got the gradient at
any point and then I've got well any
point on the parabola x1 y1 right
so I can say at x1 y1
what will gradient actually be equal to
well I'm gonna have to substitute this
point into this formula do yr DX should
have a comma there at x1 y1 do und X
will be equal to specifically at this
point the x1 on to am substituting this
coordinate into there is that okay x1 on
to a I have a point I've got a gradient
that's all I need what am I going to do
with these guys boy grading form is
really easy isn't it so I'm going to say
equation of the tangent
is what do we got here Y minus y1 equals
okay
now I want you have a look at this
because this is this is okay this is
good there's nothing wrong with this but
it's not so I'm not what I expected it
wasn't what I was meant to end up with
because we know where we're supposed to
land let me try and prove to you that
this is not what we were expecting
there's a fraction here so I can get rid
of the fraction no problem I will
multiply both sides by 2a that gives me
this now that looks a lot like what I'm
supposed to get but it's not it's not
what I'm supposed to get there's -
science we're not supposed to have minus
signs and in fact there's a whole extra
term can you see the whole extra term
where is it yeah you're like this
supposed to be just X X 1 here but here
I've got like extra stuff flying around
what's going on okay so let's see if I
can expand over here and work out where
this extra thing has come from
okay I'll expand this for reasons that
will become clear in a second as well
okay so I've expanded hmm and this is
the culprit this is the one that really
doesn't belong there's nothing like that
there's nothing like this guy in the
final line that I'm supposed to land on
do you see that it's like this the sore
thumb that's sticking out okay so how do
I get rid of this yeah Eric suggestions
okay where is my first equation here it
is okay here is my first equation okay
now x1 and y1 they're not just any
points they are points on the parabola
yeah if they're points on the parabola
that means that they satisfy this
equation that means I can take both
these guys and I can put them into here
and it's true and when a point isn't on
the parabola if I put them in what
happens it doesn't work it breaks down
it explodes okay but these are on the
parabola so I should be able to
substitute them in which gives me this
do you agree like that's just a straight
substitution of x 1 y 1 into x and y ok
and this you can see links in quite
nicely because look there see that that
X 1 squared that sore thumb that is
sticking out I can substitute for this
guy which I already have I can do some
collecting of like terms here so let's
do this on the left hand side I won't
muck around with it while I'm doing the
substitution on the right hand side this
I can replace with yeah for a Y one for
a Y 1 and now you can see where the
final line comes from I'm almost there
two lines maybe okay I'm gonna click
like terms because here and here I have
these a y1 terms so I'm gonna add for a
Y 1 to both sides that leaves me with
this and I'm pretty much there aren't I
I'll get the X X 1 on the left-hand side
like where it belongs and then I'm just
gonna factorize the other side hey
presto okay so the only weird thing
about this and just like all the other
forms you can quote this but you have to
be ready to prove it okay
the only curveball that they throw in
there is this part here going from this
line to this line okay that's that's a
weird trick we've met we don't really
use that trick but it's kind of neat
right it does simplify things I think we
can all argue that this is better than
this okay so you have to be able to
recognize that's an extension one level
trick right it's it's sort of Jedi mind
trick like whoa when did where did that
come from it's often not the kind of
thing that you would guess okay